[Music]
take a coffee filter
put it on your head
boom easter bonnet
[Music]
here's bill with another one
[Applause]
take a photo of conan o'brien
add bunny ears to it boom easter ham
[Applause]
and now
here's another one
[Applause]
take some styrofoam packing peanuts
coverman mustard
boom marshmallow peeps
don't do that kids
[Applause]
take a six pack of beer add an egg
mcmuffin
boom easter brunch
[Applause]
take a sonogram of your wife's ovaries
check them out with a magnifying glass
boom egg hunt
[Applause]
[Music]
take a dashboard jesus
attach it to some balloons
boom christ is risen
[Applause]
i'm sorry
uh i'm sorry but but bill it's actually
uh passover right now you're forgetting
not everybody celebrates easter it's a
little insensitive
take your easter bonnet
put a star of david on it
boom yamaka
it's not a yamaka bell
take a loaf of bread
smash it with a cinder block
boom matzah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
take all your favorite foods
dump them in the trash
boom
passover you